echemos un vistazo a la curva de
valoración para la titulación de una
base débil con un ácido fuerte
empezamos con 40 mililitros de una
solución 0.1 molar de amoniaco a la que
le agregamos un ácido fuerte
hcl en el inciso a nos piden encontrar
el th antes de agregar el ácido así que
sólo tenemos amoniaco en solución como
el amoniaco es una base tomara un protón
del h2o y si agregamos un h más al nh 3
obtenemos nh4 + amonio y como le
quitamos un h más al h2o nos queda h -
ahora la concentración inicial de
amoniaco es 0.1 molar entonces el
amoniaco tiene una concentración 0.1
molar y supongamos que todas
y no tenemos ninguno de los productos
ahora en el cambio perdemos una cierta
concentración de amoniaco a la que le
llamaremos x
y esta concentración de nh 3 se
transforma en nh 4 + es decir lo que
perdemos de amoniaco lo ganamos de
amonio así que tenemos más x y por lo
tanto también ganamos esa cierta
concentración de hidróxido al equilibrio
la concentración de amoniaco es 0.1
menos x para el amonio nos queda x y
para el hidróxido también tenemos x
escribamos nuestra expresión de
equilibrio como tenemos una base
escribimos café que es igual a la
concentración de los productos entre la
de los reactivos entonces en los
productos tenemos la concentración de
amonio que es x
por la concentración de hidróxido que
también es x entre la concentración de
amoniaco que es 0.1 menos
x asegúrense de ver el vídeo sobre el
equilibrio de una base débil antes de
ver este muy bien ahora sabemos que el
cable del amoniaco es 1.8 por 10 a la
menos 5 y esto es igual a x cuadrada
entre 0.1 menos x pero supongamos que x
es muy muy pequeña a comparación de 0.1
por lo tanto podemos decir que 0.1 menos
x es aproximadamente igual a 0.1 esto
nos facilita mucho las cosas
entonces usemos la calculadora tenemos
1.8 por 10 a la menos 5
0.1 y a esto le sacamos la raíz cuadrada
x es igual a 0.00 13 x es igual a 0.00
13 recordemos que x representa la
concentración de iones hidróxido al
equilibrio así que esto es igual a la
concentración de iones hidróxido ahora
si conocemos la concentración de iones
hidróxido podemos calcular el ph porque
el ph es igual a menos el logaritmo de
la concentración de iones hidróxido es
decir a menos el logaritmo de 0.00 13
usemos la calculadora menos logaritmo de
0.00 13 es igual a 2.89
h es igual a 2.89 nuestro objetivo es
encontrar el ph y recordemos que th más
p o h es igual a 14 así que simplemente
sustituimos el p
h y nos queda que el ph es igual a 14
menos 2.89 y eso es igual a 11.11 este
es el ph de la solución básica antes de
agregar el ácido si regresamos a nuestra
curva de titulación también llamada
curva de valoración podemos ver que a
los 0.0 mililitros del ácido el ph debe
ser igual a 11.11 aquí tenemos un ph
igual a 11.11
en el inciso b cuál es el ph después de
agregar 20 mililitros de la solución 0.1
molar thc el bueno sabemos que la
concentración de hcl es 0.1 molar y esto
es igual a moles / litros como agregamos
20 mililitros tenemos 20 mililitros si
movemos el punto decimal 123 lugares
esto es igual a 0.02 litros calculemos
los moles 0.1 x 0.02 es igual a 0.00 2
agregamos 0.002 moles de hc el que lo
podemos ver como h + y cl - y al agregar
un protón al agua h más o menos forman h
3 o más
qué es el número de moleste h 3 o más
que agregamos ahora cuál es la
concentración inicial de amoniaco bueno
la concentración de amoniaco es 0.1
molar y para encontrar los moles el
volumen inicial era de 40 mililitros que
si movemos el punto decimal 123 lugares
es igual a 0.04 litros
tenemos 0.04 litros
entonces para calcular los moles
simplemente multiplicamos 0.1 x 0.04 y
esto es igual a 0.004 tenemos 0.004
moles de amoniaco muy bien ahora veamos
qué sucede al agregar hcl el ácido
presente reaccionará con la base
con el amoniaco nh3 reaccionará con los
iones h 3 o más entonces aquí tenemos el
ácido y la base
así que protón amos al nh 3 para formar
nh 4 más y como le quitamos un protón al
h 3 o más nos queda h2o esta es nuestra
reacción de neutralización reacción
de neutralización
y agregamos 0.002 moles de ácido 0.002 y
empezamos con 0.00 4 moles de la base
0.004 así que todo el ácido reacciona
perdemos todo el ácido que agregamos y
también perdemos la misma concentración
de la base perdemos 0.002 moles de la
base 0.004 menos 0.00 todos es igual a
0.00 2 la mitad de la base reacciona con
el ácido y nos quedó la otra mitad sin
reaccionar
entonces si perdemos todos estos moles
de amoniaco como el amoniaco se
transforma en nh 4 más
empezamos con 0 moles de n
h 4 más después ganamos 0.002 moles y al
final tenemos 0.002 moles de amonio muy
bien ahora que ya conocemos los moles de
amonio y de amoniaco calculemos las
concentraciones sólo nos falta saber el
volumen total regresemos a nuestro
problema empezamos con 40 mililitros de
amoniaco y agregamos 20 mililitros del
ácido entonces como empezamos con 40
mililitros y agregamos 20 el volumen
total es igual a 60 mililitros es decir
0.06 litros porque movemos el punto
decimal 123 lugares entonces empecemos
con la concentración de amoniaco la
concentración de amoniaco
cual amo les entre litros tenemos
0.00 dos moles de amoniaco 0.00 todos
entre el volumen que es igual a 0.06
litros y esto es igual a usemos la
calculadora tenemos 0.002 entre 0.06
esto es igual a 0.03 33 la concentración
de amoniaco es igual a cero punto cero
333 molar ahora vamos con el amonio cuál
es la concentración del amonio bueno
tenemos el mismo número de moles 0.002 y
el volumen también es igual 0.06 litros
por lo tanto la concentración también es
igual a cero punto cero 333 molar
tenemos las mismas concentraciones del
par conjugado ácido base nh3 y nh 4 más
a esto se le conoce como solución
amortiguador también conocida como
buffet o tampón entonces nuestro
objetivo es encontrar el ph y como
tenemos una solución amortiguador o
buffer podemos usar la ecuación de
henderson hasselbeck que dice th es
igual a pk a más el logaritmo de la
concentración de a menos es decir de la
base conjugada entre la concentración de
h
entonces primero analicemos el pk a como
lo encontramos bueno nosotros conocemos
el café del amoniaco y sabemos que acá
por café es igual a 1.0 por 10 a la
menos 14
sustituimos el valor de café que es 1.8
por 10 a 5
esto es igual a 1.0 por 10 a la menos 14
entonces podemos calcular el valor de
caja que al hacer el cálculo es igual a
5.6 por 10 a la menos 10 en algún vídeo
anterior vimos que para un par con
jugado ha sido base k
por cate es igual a esto ahora ya que
calculamos que que corresponde al nh 4
más podemos calcular el pk
porque pk es igual a menos el logaritmo
de k
es decir menos logaritmo de 5.6 por 10 a
la menos 10 usemos la calculadora menos
logaritmo de 5.6 por 10 a la menos 10 es
igual a 9.25
teca es igual a 9.25 y al sustituir este
valor en nuestra ecuación de henderson
hasselbeck nos queda que el ph es igual
a 9.25 más el logaritmo de la
concentración de a menos que corresponde
al amoniaco y es de 0.0 333 molar 0.0
333 molar entre la concentración del
ácido que corresponde al nh 4 más y
también es igual a 0.0 333 molar 0.0 333
muy bien así que todo esto es igual al
logaritmo de 1 y el logaritmo de 1 es
igual a 0 por lo tanto el ph es igual al
pk
el ph es igual al 9.25 encontremos este
punto en nuestra curva de titulación
agregamos 20 mililitros de ácido
entonces a los 20 mil litros de ácido
éste es nuestro punto y encontramos que
el ph es igual a 9.25 aún nos
encontramos antes del punto de
equivalencia